let's spend some time talking about this
nfc playoff picture it is fascinating
the 49ers ain't no and peter i looked it
up yesterday there was a prop bet out
there for the last unbeaten team it was
plus 2500 so if you bet 100 on the 49ers
you won 2500 bucks which seems like it
should have been more it seems like it
was more of a long shot than that for
the 49ers to be the last unbeaten team
but here they are the one seeded eight
no saints at seven and one packers now
at seven and two and the 49ers will play
both the saints and the packers over the
course of the next four or five weeks so
we're gonna find out among those three
teams who really does rise up to the top
mike when i look at this
um
there's going to be one or two teams
that don't make it where
uh on new year's day
in their fan bases and maybe in their
front office there's going to be heck to
pay
because let's say the four teams on this
screen and i think we would you and i
would both admit that they are right now
favorites to all make the playoffs in
some cases heavy favorites
but now we go to beneath the surface
and let's look at to me there's two wild
cards and you could argue that there's
either four or five teams
that we think are going to be in
prominent positions
the rams the seahawks the vikings and
the eagles in my opinion you know you
might throw in carolina uh
but
you know it and you could throw in
carolina so if you throw in carolina
that's five teams for two spots
and to me
there are so many interesting storylines
in every one of those teams because you
look at the rams and you say how do you
go from making the super bowl one year
giving your coach everything he wants
including a new contract the next year
and then you don't make the playoffs
that is going to be a killer that's one
of the reasons why i almost look at this
rams game at pittsburgh on sunday as a
borderline must win for the rams they've
got too many hard games in the second
half of the season to miss out on this
one the seahawks they got the 49ers
twice in the second half of the season
they've got a tough role they've got
four games that they have to travel over
2 000 miles for so
the the seahawks don't have it easy the
eagles with the talent drain
uh you know especially the losses that
they've had at the receiver position
it's going to be hard for them as well
but the eagles not making the playoffs
is odd and obviously
kirk cousins was brought in to make the
playoffs and to play january football in
minnesota
if he doesn't make it if they don't make
it
do the san francisco 49ers rethink the
quarterback position as ugly as it would
be this coming off season
yeah and i'll tell you what the vikings
have and and we had this conversation
after
the the bears game when kirk cousins
looked as bad as he ever has with the
vikings you're kind of stuck with the
guy for next year it's 29.5 million
fully guaranteed do you pay
part of his salary to get someone else
to take him do you do the brock osweiler
hot potato trade where you dump his
contract and send a second round pick or
more to get rid of that cap burden and a
lot of it's going to come down to
regardless of the four great weeks that
kirk cousins had offensive player of the
month in the nfc for october it's not
going to matter if they don't get to the
playoffs and look peter i i had looked
at their schedule and i had broken it
down to seven and seven going into the
last two games against the packers and
the bears both at home and they're going
to be big spots prime time game on a
monday night against green bay and it
may be winning in losing your out week
17. they've defied my seven and seven
prediction by winning at detroit i
thought they would lose there but
they've got games coming up at the
cowboys prime time that's a recipe for a
loss based upon what we've seen from the
vikings under kirk cousins then they've
got a broncos game they should win then
it's at seattle after the bye on a
monday night another prime time game
another opportunity for a loss then the
lions there's a win at the chargers
currently set for prime time but likely
will get flexed out so maybe that
becomes winnable if they don't play it
at night but you know it's gonna be
eight and six
maybe if they're lucky nine and five
going into the last two games but they
look when would you when you look at the
rams at five and three i mean there's
gonna be one or two very good teams that
don't make it and the vikings could only
lose to the cowboys and seahawks the
rest of the way and run the table and
still get get
boxed out by the rams we just you know
it's it's uh it's going to be the rams
the vikings or the eagles two of those
teams aren't going to make it and the
teams that don't make it especially if
it's the rams of the eagles good enough
to run the table and make it to the
super bowl and they're not even going to
get a chance to do it quite possibly
yeah i think one of the things right now
that i look at when you it's it's almost
too early to have this discussion where
you say okay
which are the two which two of those
five are going to make it and which
three won't it's probably about two
weeks too early but the interesting part
of it when you look at the scenario is
that you know uneasy lies the crown on
the heads of
some of these divisions dallas for
instance you look at dallas's schedule
and you look at philadelphia's schedule
and again look they're kind of similar
but dallas is probably uh just a little
bit harder
one of the reasons is the new england
game
for dallas is is you know in new england
philadelphia is going to have new
england at home not that new england has
struggled on the road or anything like
that but
i i think it's an advantage obviously to
play them in philadelphia and the one
other thing when you look at at the at
the cowboys schedule you know that's a
deceiving last month
because i don't think it's ever easy to
win at the bears
uh even when they're a terrible
offensive team
and and then you have to play at
philadelphia in a game that the eagles
might have to have to stay alive so that
and you know the rams at home the last
time they had the rams at home the rams
killed them put up 35 or however many
points so to me i think that's a real
difficult schedule that the cowboys have
never mind the fact that that could be a
uh a two loss buffalo team coming in
uh when they play them on thanksgiving
afternoon
and you know what there's one team
that's not on the board that we need to
mention because the detroit lions at
three four and one
they could have won
each of the four games that they lost
and that tie was a game that they led by
18 points in the fourth quarter but they
gave the chiefs fits they could have won
that game the packers game on that
monday night is a game that the lions
could have won the vikings game 42-30
was much closer than that and the
raiders game went right down to the wire
and i mentioned the lions because
if they could get those breaks to go
their way in the second half they could
pull themselves into this conversation
as well peter
i mean mike
do you have faith
in the detroit lions to go six and two
and and and i don't i don't care what
the schedule is okay
but
the detroit lions have not been a team
that you would look at and say man i
think they could go six and two in any
stretch of any season and that's the
only thing i agree they have probably
played a little bit better than their
record indicates uh i think they got a
huge
uh
you know they they got hugely jobbed by
the officials at green bay
uh so look
and again nobody wants to hear that and
now it doesn't matter the packers have
to go are the lions have to go six and
two in their last eight to have a decent
shot to make the playoffs yeah and even
six and two doesn't guarantee them
anything it would get them a nine six
and one record and that's where that tie
comes in handy because it trumps nine
and seven but you may need to go seven
and one and i don't have faith that
they're going to do it but when you
consider
that it's a little push here and it's
just it's one big game where they can
bust through you know they got the
cowboys coming to town
week
12. if they could just steal that one
maybe that's the thing that propels them
forward so i just don't want to overlook
the lions because they're on the fringe
and if they could win a couple of games
they could make things very interesting
down the stretch the 49ers a team and i
think you mentioned this on in football
morning in america this week the idea
that they've got that little mini round
robin coming up against the packers and
the saints the 49ers despite the 8-0
record they could still end up having to
play
in the wild card round how they could
still end up the fifth seed or the sixth
seed when you consider they've got the
seahawks and the rams in their own
division
well mike this is the point i was trying
to make in the column and that is that
right now everybody looks at the nfc
midway through the season after nine
weeks and they say wow 49ers dominant
you know look at how they've played
recently and and yes
absolutely correct they have been
dominant
but i just look at the opportunity with
their schedule two games against seattle
one game against the rams
two games in eight days on the road both
against new orleans and baltimore
nobody in the nfl down the stretch has a
schedule as challenging
week in and week out
as the san francisco 49ers so you look
at them right now and you say okay
that's the 1c2 at worst i get it and
that's probably correct
but if they lose more than a couple of
these games down the stretch you're
absolutely right they could go from
being the last unbeaten team in football
to having to win three games on the road
to make the super bowl as the five seed
so there's a lot at stake for the 49ers
in the next seven weeks
a lot of similarities to that patriots
schedule as well fatten up on bad teams
early and then all of a sudden you get
that that uh reality of a much tougher
schedule down the stretch can you hold
on the question is more relevant for the
patriots because they've already lost
but it could become very relevant for
the 49ers
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports